welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul aka the alter ego of
the world's worst superhero
the spoiler man and we have some new
images that have just brought some light
to the dark knight we've been
experiencing in 2020.
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down everything and going over
more of the evidence to support the
theory that barry kiyowin is the mad
hatter
there might be some spoilers here so if
you don't want anything about the film
ruined then i highly recommend that you
turn off now
make sure you click the thumbs up button
if you enjoy this video
and also subscribe to the channel to
slide down the bat poll with us
every week terrible terrible pun as
always but uh thank you for clicking
this
now let's get into the video okay so
since i saw you last time
we had some terrible news in regards to
the release date of the film
due to the pandemic june has taken its
spot in october next year
and the movie is now scheduled to
release on the 4th of march
2022 it's gonna be ice if we ever get
the chance to see it
but i have to admit when i first heard
this news i felt like
a little snowflake crumbling away
completely devastated that the film we
were supposed to be getting next year
was put on ice even more
so bad however today there have been
some images
that have melted my cold cold heart
these show robert pattinson in full
action
and it pretty much confirms that all the
rumors about him being sent home from
the project for not being in shape
are delusions delusions
i don't want to focus on those reports
too much as you know they don't come
from the best
sources and i think they've been posted
kind of just to fit the narrative that
pattinson is going to be a bad batman
which is something that is still being
pushed by certain aspects of the fan
community
even though in my opinion the trailer
should have shut that all down
but everyone is entitled to their
opinion just don't go
making stuff up for clicks you're bad
bad boy
now if you can't see mine back to
earlier in the air i don't know exactly
when
as it feels so long ago but there was a
point when filming was being set up
outside a courthouse in liverpool
this featured several railings and a
warner brothers truck to confirm that it
was indeed
going to be part of the film however
filming had to be shut down
and thus we waited for about 6 7
84 years until we finally found out
today that this is actually going to be
showing
what looks like it could be part of the
funeral scene or something to do with
the death of the mayor
the working title of vengeance has been
displayed at the set but this is very
much just a production name
as we do know from the trailer poster
and logo
that it will indeed be called the batman
now from the trailer we also know that
the funeral will be happening in a
cathedral
so i'm still unsure that these are
actually linked as the outside of this
building looks different to the interior
that we saw in the film
however that is something that movies
just do in general
and the photo that's at his funeral does
seem to be there as well
so they could be one in the same look i
don't know
please don't click away now the footage
that we have seen of the event
also makes it seem like the people are
dressed for such an occasion
and there are several black umbrellas
and black suits which are typical of
funerals
bruce is also wearing the same clothes
that he was in the trailer at this point
and with his hair being the same it does
seem to all be linked
world's greatest detective right here
now if they are then i can imagine that
this happens just before the events of
the funeral
as we know there's an explosion at it
that could have caused damage to the
picture at this point
again not sure how they tend to do it
with these kinds of stands
and they may have printed more than one
but hey let me know if you know as we
don't know if they're linked or not
if only if only there was some way i
could quickly find out everything on
earth at the touch of a button
but i guess not now from what we can see
it does seem there are people paying
tribute to the fallen mayor
as several bouquets are placed around
the stand as we know from the behind the
scenes info
the riddler killed him because he was
incredibly corrupt
and it is interesting to see how the
people still adore the political figure
even though he was likely a monster
almost like real life there
we also get a look at what happens to be
bruce wayne's car
and it's very slick and grounded whilst
also feeling
very similar to the one in year one as
we already know he does have a batmobile
but it seems like he's sort of keeping
his personal life in line with the
choice of car
the guy obviously loves them and
probably adapted the batmobile from a
similar model to this
in order to develop his ride yes it
comes in black
now we've seen several other vehicles
including a news van
that is obviously reporting on the event
probably doing a better job than me as
well
there was also a police car that was
hanging around the area
which was likely there to provide
security now what we all want to talk
about though
is robert pattinson's bruce wayne and
there's been several high quality shots
of him posted online
they show him attending the deal with
his spider-man 3 hairstyle firmly
in place and very much give this this
dark and gritty feel
now a lot of complaints i've seen over
the film are that this guy doesn't
really seem like he has a bruce wayne
playboy persona
and instead he's pretty much just a
depressed emo that would likely be
suspected of being batman straight away
i will say that though in the graphic
novel zero yeah
bruce in that hadn't really developed
his alter ego yet
and throughout the work he's spent a lot
of his time either as
batman or in his cave working away that
seems to be very much in place in this
film too
and even upon attending events he's very
low key
and at points even hiding away and
spying on the proceedings
i think throughout the film we will see
him develop this persona
as it's only after alfred convinces him
in the comics that he really starts to
adopt one
so lots of things going on here and
another interesting element is that
barry kyoen helps bruce to park his car
i don't have an image of this but have
heard things from people at the scene
that state he was indeed there
and yeah dude dude bro come on trust me
bro no it's me
it's me this time yeah it's me now if
you checked out our last video on the
batman
you'll know that we heard from extras on
the set that one character
wasn't who they were being listed as and
that it went far deeper than what we've
been told
in the video we discussed how keown
could be the joker
but another theory that we went over was
that he might actually be the mad hatter
and would be masquerading as a policeman
in order to carry out his crimes
within the confines of the law as i said
we've already done a full breakdown on
the subject which will be linked at the
end
but today we uncovered a bit more
evidence to support that he could be mad
hatter
and that is because on the 31st of
january he actually posted an image of
himself under a hat
now shout out to brooklyn batman for
discovering this and this photo was
actually taken
before his casting in the film was
announced at the time the film would
have been close to having him brought in
and it's only because of the pandemic
that it was delayed
actors often do these kind of things to
tease what will be happening with them
but this normally comes post
announcement and not before
as at this point in time we had
absolutely no way of publicly knowing
that he was connected to the property
around the time of this image coming out
it was actually being reported that both
firefly and mad hatter would be making
up the additional villains in the movie
so seeing this does seem to make a lot
of sense when we start to put the pieces
together
either way whether he is or isn't i'm so
glad that we have some amazing new
images from the film
that we can spend hours looking at it
was said that filming would take place
solely inside for the foreseeable future
so i'm glad that they actually have some
more outdoor shots minus the social
distancing
as of making this video we also have
reports that zoe kravitz is at the scene
however i haven't been able to verify
this so by the time i posted this video
hopefully we have a bit more information
the film and this look
is absolutely phenomenal though and
hopefully it's not going to be too long
before we get some more amazing new
images from the project
i kind of hope they move the release
date up a bit but yeah for now
at least we have something like this to
talk about obviously i'd love to hear
your thoughts on this video
and the images so make sure you comment
below and let me know
if you enjoyed it then please drop a
thumbs up and make sure you check out
our breakdown of our barricade and
theories in full
which are going to be linked at the end
don't forget we're also giving away
three copies of the marvel phase one box
set
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of october so make
sure you get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see contents early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat to us on a
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you been the best i've been paul i'll
see you next time take care
peace
you